shares of stock represent how much of a
company a person owns puffs incorporated
is owned by Peter Paul and Mary
Peter owns 4050 shares
Paul owns two thousand five hundred ten
shares and Mary owns 40 200 or four
thousand two hundred shares suppose the
company made a profit this year of 1
million five hundred thousand dollars if
each shareholder gets a proportion of
the total profit that is equal to the
proportion of the share they own how
much money does Mary receive so first
let's think about what fraction or what
percentage or what proportion of the
total profit should Mary receive so Mary
owns Mary owns four thousand to two
hundred shares so four thousand two
hundred and how many total shares are
there in the company well the total the
only owners of this company are Peter
Paul and Mary so the total number of
shares are the sum of Peter Paul and
Mary shares so we know we know that
Peter owns four thousand and fifty
shares 4050 we know that Paul owns two
thousand five hundred ten two thousand
five hundred ten and of course we know
that Mary Owens 4,200 4,200 so let's
figure this is the fraction of this this
is the fraction of the profit that Mary
should be getting so let's figure out
this with a calculator so this is going
to be it's going to be four thousand two
hundred divided by divided by four
thousand fifty plus two thousand five
hundred and ten plus four thousand two
hundred and so Mary should get 0.39 of
the profit or if we talk about in terms
of percentage it would be thirty nine
percent of the profit so this right over
here is 0.3 nine Oh actually let me just
leave it like that so it's going to be
so this is the
is approximately equal to this is
approximately equal to 0.39 and so if we
want to figure out how much profit she
gets she gets this much times the total
profit so Mary gets Mary gets so she
gets 0.39 and this is the exact quantity
right over here 0.39 is the
approximation so approximately 0.3 this
little squiggly equal sign is how I say
approximately she's going to get zero
point three nine times the total profit
which is 1 million five hundred 1
million five hundred thousand dollars
and so let's go back to our calculator
and so this is we said approximately
zero point three nine this is the exact
value I can get that exact value again
at least in this calculator by saying
second answer this literally means the
previous answer so this is literally
this number right over here point three
nine zero three three four whatever this
is so this exact quantity times
$1,500,000 one two three there we go
this $1,500,000 got to make sure I have
the right number of zeros there and that
gets us 585 thousand dollars five
hundred won and we need to round to the
nearest penny and 86 cents so let me put
that someplace where I can see it so let
me so this is going to be equal to this
is equal to five hundred and eighty five
thousand dollars five hundred and one
and if we round 86 cents so not bad for
one year for Mary she should be able to
live quite well just on her just on her
dividends from puffs incorporated